[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning nascar
fans are heading to florida for american
racing's
biggest event the daytona 500 is all set
for this sunday
valentine's day and could be the largest
in-person sports crowd since the start
of the pandemic
nascar faced a number of challenges in
2020 including
navigating both covet and racial
inequity mark straussman looks at how
the sport is adapting to a new normal
and they're also looking forward
here comes hamilton up the outside crash
into the wall
lots of businesses think they move 200
miles an hour
nascar really does and here's the on
rushing cory lejoy
and it survives like driver ryan newman
after this fiery wreck last year at
daytona
covid has become one more obstacle to
swerve around
at daytona on sunday thirty thousand
fans will watch the race
instead of the typical one hundred
thousand plus
and on the track our athletes are in a
car by themselves they're already
wearing gloves and a helmet they're
isolated from each other
dave alpern is the president of joe
gibbs racing one of nascar's most
successful teams
the ones who do get to go to the race
what will they notice is different i
think what will be a little bit
different is
um it just won't be completely full but
i think once the race starts you know
it's going to sound the same it's going
to look the same on the racetrack
nascar has had to shift gears on racial
sensitivity
with its southern roots and fan base of
mostly white men
stock cars historically raced for
checkered flags
and rebel flags bubba wallace it's only
top-tier black driver
called out for change last summer we'll
just keep moving on we'll keep pushing
the needle and fighting for for what's
right in this sport
nascar banned the flags the black lives
movement
had arrived on pit row driver joey
logano
a past daytona 500 winner you know the
only way you can really get
through any kind of conflict is trying
to understand the other person's side
and i think that's the biggest thing
that we all can do is just listen and
learn and try to understand what that is
then i feel like we've done that
and i think now there's some real impact
that's coming along with it and nascar
has a new racing team
co-owned by michael jordan probably the
most famous athlete of all time
in our sport really means a lot and it's
something that's really you know special
driving for team jordan in the number 23
car
bubba wallace i think he's an
inspiration to many people
and i think that was long overdue i
think that reflects what's at nascar's
core
you know that was one example of them
doing the right thing i think you saw a
lot of examples where
every driver and every team had bubba's
back in that
and i think that was the right thing to
do you gotta wanna
it's a famous nascar line about winning
races and now
about much more for cbs this morning
mark strassman atlanta
it's gonna be interesting i know
remember that when bubba went through
that thing
he felt very supported by the nascar
community they came out and a big show
of support
michael jordan now getting involved i
think he's gonna bring a whole different
audience a whole different dimension
well i'm a new audience member for that
word gotta wanna gotta wanna you gotta
wanna win
i guess is the sentence there you go